[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Geoffrey Didier bonjour merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes députés européens secrétaire
général délégué des républicains on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Fabrice Vess
Redon du groupe ébras les journaux
régionaux de l'Est de la France bonjour
Fabrice bonjour bonjour bonjour jeoffre
on commence évidemment par la loi
immigration puisque ça y est couenvoie
des débats à l'Assemblée nationale cet
après-midi des débats qui pourraient
tourner court puisque l'opposition a
déposer une motion de rejest si est
voter le texte s'arrêterait l'examen du
texte s'arrêterait est-ce que l'ensemble
des députés les républicains votteront
cette motion de rejet je ne peux pas
vous dire encore il y aura une décision
collective collégiale qui sera prise cet
après-midi mais il y a une chose qui est
certaine c'est que ce texte dans sa
version de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale ne nous convient
pas il ne nous convient pas parce qu'il
a détricoté méthodiquement la version
qui était tout à fait convenable qui
était celle qui avait été obtenue par la
majorité de droite au Sénat elle ne nous
convient pas donc nous verrons bien s'il
y a une motion de rejet qui qui est
adoptée ou pas mais de toute
façon le projet de loi immigration tel
qu'il
estourd mais sur la motion de rejet ça
dépend beaucoup de vous est-ce que vous
souhaitez vous que les députés les
républicains la vote encore une fois je
suis député au Parlement européen trop
de respect
sûr j'ai trop de respect pour les
institutions trop de respect pour mes
collègues parlementaires de l'Assemblée
nationale pour décider à leur place ils
décideront eux-mêmes mais ce qui est
certain je vous le dis en tout cas c'est
que la version de la commission des loi
c'est celle qui est sur la table de
l'Assemblée nationale nous la rejetons
alors je vous pose la question TR est-ce
que si aujourd'hui vous étiez député
vous la voteriezv cette mon on peut le
faire cinq fois si vous voulez je vous
dis juste je vous je vais vous dire
personnellement
je rejette la version qui est sur la
table de l'Assemblée
nationalepr pour une motion de rejet ou
pour un refus de vote du du texte à la
fin ça revient au même vous pouvez la
rejeter et laisser le débat se faire en
séance et remodifier le texte en séance
mais avec une majorité de gauche ça ne
va pas fonctionner parce que Géral darin
est un ministre de droite d'une majorité
de gauche Gérald Darmanin même avec
toute sa bonne volonté fait semblant de
vouloir prendre nos amendements
et en réalité il est lui-même prisonnier
d'une majorité de gauche donc ce texte
tel qu'il existe actuellement doit être
rejeté et je déplore je déplore que
l'Assemblée nationale a rejeté le projet
de loi constitutionnel qui avait étéi
sur la table par Eric cotti et qui
permet de reprendre la main en matière
migratoire qui permet qui permet
d'imposer les plafonds migratoires
c'est-à-dire de choisir son immigration
et de s'imposer ainsi aux traités
européens et et à la jurisprudence
européenne et par exemple à l'article 8
de la Convention européenne des droits
de l'homme qui énonce une automaticité
du regroupement famili si nous voulons
mais c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est pas
la procéd
Parlement je vous dire pour cette non
mais juste pour vous nous dites tu aura
une décision collégiale est-ce que vous
êtes sûr qu'elle sera si collégiale que
ça la décision et que tout le monde sera
sur la même ligne dans votre groupe mais
si vous mettez 62 hommes et femmes
ensemble il y a toujours des
sensibilités différentes je crois qu'en
revanche nous sommes tous d'accord pour
dire c'est pour ça que j'insiste
là-dessus ce matin et que je préfère
parler du fond que de la forme et que de
la procédure nous sommes tous
d'ACP li
r mais mais bien sûr mais que encore une
fois comprenez bien parce que ceux qui
nous regardent ils ne suivent pas tous
les épisodes parlementaires heure par
heure ce qui les intéresse c'est est-ce
que le projet de loi immigration voulu
par le gouvernement aura pour
conséquence plus d'immigration
ou moins d'immigration il y a
aujourd'hui 10 % de la population qui
est étrangère 70 Catherine Duma
sinatrice de Paris était sur le plateau
il y a quelques instants 70 % de la
délinquence violente à Paris est issue
des étrangers bon 27 % des détenus sont
des étrangers il y a selon des
estimations fiables 900000 clandestins
sur notre territoire et lorsqu'ils
reçoivent une obligation de quitter le
territoire français seulement
un/1 repart dans son pays et en plus de
cela il y a une explosion des demandes
d'asile avec cette année a priori entre
130 et 140000 demandes d'asile et
lorsqu'il y a des débouté du droit
d'asile il reste là aussi dans 90 % des
cas sur notre territoire donc la vraie
la seule question c'est est-ce qu'on
veut plus d'immigration ou moins
d'immigration mais làdus vous avez
d'accord avec geréral haranin lui dit
que c'est le plus ferme de ces 20
dernières années c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai nous nous voulons moins
d'immigration eux eux ils veulent du en
même temps c'està-dire un zeste de
fermeté et en réalité une explosion
desrégularisation en même temps puisque
je vous rappelle quand même que dans le
texte de sa version de la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale un
clandestin qui vient sur notre
territoire c'estàd quelqu'un qui ne
respecte pas nos lois nos règles et nos
valeurs qui est depuis 3 ans sur le
territoire et qui a travaillé seulement
8 mois pour être régularisé c'està-dire
qu'en fait ce que veut monsieur daranin
ou en tout cas ce qu'accepte monsieur un
prisonnier de sa majorité de gauche
peut-être encore une fois malgré sa
bonne volonté personnelle c'est de
mettre en place une régularisation
massive comment voulez-vous que je ne
rejette pas ce texte et cette majorité
de gauche qui nous emmène encore une
fois dans le mur le en même temps
matière migratoire ça ne peut pas
fonctionner ce que veut Gérald Darmanin
c'est que vous saisissiez la main que le
gouvernement vous tend et dit-il sans
cela vous ne saurez pas quoi répondre à
vos électeurs est-ce qu'ils se trompent
mais nos électeurs euh ils veulent de la
fermeté ils veulent de la clarté nous
sommes clairs depuis le début depuis de
nombreux mois Eric cotti a encore une
fois mis un projet de loi
constitutionnel sur la table disant si
nous voulons vraiment reprendre la main
et être souverain en matière migratoire
il n'y a qu'une seule solution c'est
modifier la Constitution monsieur
darmanan veut-il modifier la
Constitution oui ou pas il a répondu
lui-même en disant non en faisant
rejeter le projet loi constitutionnel
avec les amis de Monsieur Mélenchon donc
la clarté elle est de notre côté mais ai
si vous votez la motion ROG vous
voteriez aussi cette ce soir avec les
amis de Monsieur Mélenchon non non non
Mo si on vote la motion de rejet oui non
mais attendez moi la motion de rejet
c'est de la procédure parlementaire ce
sera quand même un vote avec les amis de
mon regardez la différence si si les
amis de Monsieur Mélenchon disent qu'il
fait beau et qu'il a du soleil je dirais
qu'il y a du soleil je vais pas mentir
sous prétexte de ne pas voter la même
chose que les amis de Mélenchon mais
c'est c'est sur le fond que Monsieur
Darmanin a fait voter le gouvernement
avec Monsieur Mélenchon c'est pas sur un
exercice de procédure parlementaire ça
n'a rien à foir encore une fois ne
confondons pas par respect pour ceux qui
nous regardent le fond et la forme sur
le fond nous sommes clairs et sur le
fond monsieur dararmanin et le
gouvernement sont très ambigus oui à
votre gauche j'ai cité Géral Darmanin je
vais vous citer quelqu'un à gauche
maintenant Yan brossa qui dis plus à
gauche oui encore plus encore plus à
gauche porte parole du Parti communiste
élu à Paris euh qui estime que la copie
des républicains hein qui a été écrite
réécrite au Sénat est un texte
d'immigration digne je le cite d'un
tracte du Front national est-ce que ça
vous heurte mais c'est la vieille
rangain de la gauche depuis des années
des années et à force de ne pas vouloir
elle pose elle pose la question de votre
ligne par rapport au rassemblement
nationalû à force mais je vais vous la
je vais vous énoncer la différence à
force de ne pas vousir maîtriser les
flux migratoires à force de laisser
venir un nombre incommensurable d'étrang
sans avoir la capacité de les accueillir
et bien on se retrouve avec des
étrangers qui et je le dis à Yan brossa
puisqu'il est sénateurs du 18e
arrondissement avec des étrangers qui se
retrouvent por de la chapelle c'est ça
la dignité humaine c'est ça le
communisme tel que le rêve ou le
néocommunisme que rêve monsieur don rêve
monsieur brossa je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ça ne serait-ce que par respect
pour la dignité humaine de ces hommes et
de ses femmes que nous ne devons pas
faire venir si nous ne pouvons pas les
accueillir c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous sommes différents aussi du
rassemblement national le Rassemblement
National veut immigration zéro ils l'ont
toujours dit ils ont toujours été
notamment au Parlement européen les
véhicules d'une immigration zéro je n'ai
jamais été pour l'immigration zéro
jamais je suis juste pour qu'on retrouve
la souveraineté migratoire et qu'on
décide souverainement chaque année à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat le
nombre d'immigrés que nous voulons faire
venir autre différence avec le
rassemblement national je suis très
attaché à la tradition d'accueil des des
réfugiés politiques qui fait honneur à
la France ce n'est pas du tout le
discours du rassemblement national j'ai
des différences fondamentales avec le
rassemblement national j'en ai fait un
livre qui s'appelé la fronde nationale
mais qui disait aussi que il ne faut pas
nous ne devons pas juger et condamner
moralement tous ces Français qui
considèrent aujourd'hui que le mode de
vie français s étiolé et que nous avons
fait venir un nombre bien trop important
d'étrangers ce qui fait que eux-mêmes ne
se sentent plus chez eux en France et ça
nous devons l'entendre et ça je ne le
méprise pas et c'est une différence
fondamentale aussi que j'ai avec Yan
brossa interrogé hier dans le journal Le
Parisien sur les députés les
républicains qui veulent voter le projet
de ériic soti répond nous prendrons des
sanctions pour une ou deux
individualités qui ont franchi toutes
les lignes de la trahison c'est quoi les
lignes de la trahison les lignes de la
trahison ou en tout cas de la
déloyauté c'est celle par exemple qui
considère à être présent à un événement
d'un ministre
du gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron pour
sa rentrée politique Géral ceux qui sont
allé à tourcoin voilà plutôt que de
venir à la rentrée politique des
républicains c'est-à-dire que c'est
c'est comme si demain vous alliez à la
conférence de presse de rentrée de TF1
qui aurait lieu le jour même de la
conférence de de presse de rentrée de
Public Sénat moi je comprendrai que le
directeur de la rédaction de public S se
disent mais or monchini elle est où et
bien c'est exactement la même chose donc
il y a une question de cohérence il y a
une question clarté vous m'appeliez à la
clarté il y a quelques instants j'estime
que ceux qui sont clairs parce que ell
les même pas ceux-là ils sont même pas
igux ils sont clair dans l'autre sens
c'estàd que eux ils ont fait un choix
mais il y a aucun problème à faire un
choixumus pourquoi c'était fin août
c'est pourquoi vous attendez aujourd'hui
pour prendre ces sanctions ah mais parce
que on a pardon d'autres chats à
fouetter d'autres défis à relever
d'autres urgences donc c'est parce que
vous craignez que ces députés
soutiennent Gérald armanan sur le projet
de loi immigration mais mais en fait ces
députés soutiennent déjà l'action du
gouvernement encore une fois il n'y a
aucun problème chacun fait ses choix
politiques mais encore faut-il les
assumer derrière ils seront exclus du
parti c'est ce que vous souhaitez je je
je ne suis pas président des
républicains je suis membre du bureau
politique des républicain je pense que
chacun doit être clair mais cohérent
avec lui-même et cohérent avec le le
groupe d'hommes et de femmes dans lequel
il évolue et cohérent avec l'étiquette
politique qui lui a aussi permis d'être
député vous avez d'autres individualités
euh au sein des républicains il y a
notamment Aurélien Pradier qui est qui
conteste souvent la ligne du parti qui
conteste beaucoup les choix qui sont
faits par les républicains au Sénat
est-ce que lui il a encore sa place dans
le
parti ne comptez pas sur moi parce que
c'est une question de caractère euh pour
me transformer en machine et exclusion
c'est pas c'est pas ma philosophie j'ai
jceon peut reprocher à des gens d'aller
voir Gérald dararmanin et de
potentiellement le soutenir et en même
temps garder des gens qui critiquent
beaucoup la ligne des républicain du
Sénat c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une
critique interne des choix qui sont
faits par votre parti mais sur
l'immigration Aurélien Prad est très
clair il veut la fermeté il n'est
aucunement ambigu à l'égard du
gouvernement il a été critique avec le
texte qui a été voté ici au Sénat oui
mais il a dit clairement qu'il fallait
s'opposer fermement à ce texte du en
même temps voulu par le gouvernement je
suis d'accord avec lui donc il a encore
sa place au salur mais écoutez on n'est
pas là encore pour exclure tout tous
ceux qui ne pensent pas exactement comme
nous enfin la droite elle est riche de
de ses sensibilités je peux vous citer
un nombre important de membres du bureau
politique avec lesquels j'ai sur tel ou
tel défi de société des sensibilités
différentes heureusement heureusement
que nous sommes pas des petits poids et
que nous pensons tous exactement la même
chose sinon vous vous ennuieriez sur les
plateaux et sinon nous nous ennuierions
aussi dans les débats politiques et dans
les bureaux politiques la seule chose
c'est que il y a des règles à respecter
qui sont des règles minimales de
cohérence et quand on est clair mais
avec le gouvernement plutôt qu'avec les
républicains on devrait soi-même sans
attendre d'être exclu ou ou ou dénoncer
parce que c'est pas ça l'idée d'une
formation politique d'une formation
politique c'est de
rassembler non mais encore une fois moi
je préfère qu'on parle du fond plutôt
que de parler des uns des autres des
ambitions personnelles qui sont tout à
fait légitime en politique je n'en suis
pas dénué parlons du fond et de ce qui
intéresse les Français et la question de
savoir si on veut plus ou moins
d'immigration ça ça intéresse ceux qui
nous regardent des porominés on va
parler d'autres sujets Emmanuel Macron
veut un rendez-vous avec la nation en
janvier pour je cite rappeler la France
à elle-même et à ce qu'Al est il veut
envoyer un message d'unité à un pays
fracturé il a raison
encore mais ça vous fait rire encore
c'estàd ça va servir à rien mais attz on
a eu des conventions quand même
important on a que le Président de la
République s'exprime envoie un message
ah pour s'exprimer il est plutôt prolixe
hein euh on a eu les conventions
citoyennes on a eu euh les le grand
débat
euh on a eu le Conseil national de la
refondation on en a jamais vu les
conclusions on a eu les rencontres de
Saint-Denis et maintenant voulez qu'on
ait les assises de l'unité la nation
mais de qui se moquet-on en fait plus je
j'observe Emmanuel Macron plus je me dis
qu'il fait de la cavalerie politique
vous savez il y y a ceux qui font la
cavalerie budgétaire qui passent leur
argent d'un compte à l'autre pour
échapper à leur propre dette et bien
Emmanuel Macron fait exactement la même
chose avec la politique c'est-à-dire que
il court après l'échec de son bilan en
essayant de devancer les critiques et ça
va durer combien de temps ça va durer
jusqu'à 2027 mais le problème c'est que
pendant que lui court et il n'est plus
en marche il court et bien la France
elle tombe elle tombe avec ce qu' disait
être son grand succès c'est-à-dire un
chômage qui avait baissé mais qui
remonte avec une dette publique qui
explose avec une insécurité qui explose
avec une immigration qui n'est
absolument pas régulée je vous rappelle
quand même qu'en
2012 nous avions chaque année 35000
reconduites à la frontière aujourd'hui
nous en avons que 15000 alors même qu'en
valeur absolue le nombre de clandestins
a explosé vous voyez quand même il y a
je parle des ambitions et des uns et des
autres des initiatives ou des stratagèes
des stratagèmes de communication
d'Emmanuel Macron mais il faut qu'on
parle de la France il faut qu'on parle
du bilan il faut qu'on parle de ce qui
est en train de se passer et qui est
explosif explosif bon donc c'est ça qui
m'intéresse dans un entretien au Journal
du Dimanche Édouard Philippe l'ancien
Premier ministre a jugé bien possible
qu'il y ait une forme nouvelle de
racisme antiblanc est-ce que vous
partagez ces mots bien sûr parce que le
racisme serait uniquement à l'égard de
ceux qui ne sont pas blancs bien sûr
qu'il y a du racisme antiblanc bien sûr
que dans certains quartiers je le dis en
tant que conseiller régional
d'île-de-fance je sais à quel point
certains maires nous relaent le racisme
qui existe où certains ne se sentent
plus en France c'est pour ça que je vous
disais que je ne veux absolument pas
juger condamner moralement ceux qui se
se sont tournés vers les extrêmes non
pas par conviction non pas par adhésion
mais tout simplement par ralbol et cela
nous devons les entendre et tous ceux
qui aujourd'hui et je pense au français
de la communauté juive qui pour certains
dans le valdoise ou encenne saint-enis
nous disent mais on ne peut plus être
juif en France on n'enseigne plus la
chose dans les manuels scolaires de nos
enfants oui il faut sauver aussi ces
Français parce que nous devons quand
même regarder les Français qui souffrent
je pense aussi à tous ces Français qui
aujourd'hui ne peuvent même pas se
permettre de se payer une mutuelle et
qui voi que certains au gouvernement ou
au sein de la gauche refuse de réformer
l'aide médicale d'État ça aussi ce n'est
pas juste vous voyez la seule chose qui
m'importe la France la France est en
train de devenir raciste jeanfroier non
il n'y a pas de de de racisme systémique
il y a des
individualités qui sont racistes et qui
ne sont pas suffisamment sanctionné il y
a un problème aujourd'hui en France avec
l'autorité judiciaire qui tolère trop de
choses ce n'est pas de la faute des
magistrats c'est de la faute des choix
budgétaires c'estàdire que nous avons
une popérisation rampante des services
fondamentaux de l'État qui est le
véritable scandale avec un Budet de la
justice qui augmente
considérablementu pas suffisamment ça
fait 3 ans qu'il augmente oui mais pas
suffisamment tout ce qui va dans le bon
sens je l'applaudirai dès demain mais je
vous dis qu'aujourd'hui il doit y avoir
une concentration des budgets sur les
missions fondamentales de l'État il
suffit d'aller regarder l'état de
certains commissariats et de certaines
cases de gendarmerie et il suffit
d'échanger avec les magistrats qui
aujourd'hui sont débordés et ne peuvent
plus traiter les dossiers notamment les
petits dossiers de délinquence qui
mériteraient aussi d'être traité parce
que je crois par exemple que les petites
peines de de prison sont en fait
fondamentales contrairement à ce que
l'on a souvent pensé la ministre hor
Berger a dévoolé son plan pour
responsabiliser les parents mise en
place de travaux d'intérêt général pour
les parents défaillants paiement d'une
contribution financière pour les parents
d'enfants coupables de dégradation
amende pour les parents ne se présentant
pas aux audiences qui concernent leurs
enfants vous saluez la fermeté du
gouvernement chiche mais Emmanuel Macron
est président depuis 6 ans ça fait 6 ans
et il s'était toujours pas rendu compte
qu'il y avait un problème d'autorité
parentale et d'autorité tout simplement
dans notre pays donc chiche mais vous
savez nous nous agissons nous n'avons
pas attendu Aurore berger ou le
gouvernement pour agir nous à l'échelle
européenne et je le dis en tant que
rapporteur du texte digital services Act
DSA la première régulation au monde des
réseaux sociaux nous avons agi pour
résister aux gfam c'estd les Google
Apple Facebook qui sont aujourd'hui des
entreprises aussi puissantes que des
états pour dire si vous ne retirez pas
les contenus par exemple de
cyberhcèlement parce que nous savons à
quel point les jeunes sont aujourd'hui
victimes d'harcèlement à l'école et bien
nous pourrons émettre des sanctions à
partir du trimestre prochain allant
jusqu'à 6 % du chiffre d'affaires
mondial il y a aujourd'hui un défi
fondamental qui est celui de la
régulation des réseaux sociaux de la
régulation des écrans un enfant de 6 ans
de 6 ans en France passe autant de temps
devant les écrans qu'il n'en passe à
l'école ça fait réfléchir un mot sur un
texte qui sera présenté mercredi en
Conseil des ministres qui vise à
constitutionnaliser l'IVG est-ce que les
républicains le soutiendront en tout cas
à titre personnel je le soutiendrai je
le soutiendrai parce que c'est un acquis
sociétal fondamental qui avait été mise
en place par la droite et par Simon
veille et aussi je le soutiendrai parce
qu'il faut anticiper oui certains nous
disent aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas de
remise en cause du droit à l'avortement
mais devons-nous attendre comme ce fut
le cas aux États-Unis comme c'est
aujourd'hui le cas en Argentine qu'il y
ait des remises en cause pour agir je
crois que pour une fois que nous
anticipons c'est une bonne chose en
revanche à certains membbres de votre
parti parce que c'est un texte qui
divise à l'intériur encore une fois
parlant du fond moi je vous me poser la
question à titre personnel je suis
favorable à la constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG afin de préserver le droit des
femmes à choisir leur vie et à choisir
si elles souhaitent avorter ou si elles
ne souhaitent pas avorter en revanche il
y a des clauses de conscience des
médecins et cela je les respecte en
revanche il doit aussi y avoir des
politiques de prévention parce qu'on
sait très bien qu'il y a certaines
pressions parfois masculines sur
certaines femmes pour qu'elles avortent
tout ça doit être pris en compte avec
humanité avec dignité mais aussi avec
anticipation question au députés
européens puisque orsela Vian la
présidente de la Commission européenne
s'exprime ce matin dans le Parisien sur
la guerre en Ukraine et elle dit que le
soutien à kiief doit rester sans faille
une victoire russe en Ukraine serait
lourde de menace pour ses voisins
européen est-ce que vous craignez qu'il
y a un affaiblissement du 27 des 27 dans
ce soutien à l'Ukraine oui je crains
qu'il y a un
affaiblissement de l'Occident des
États-Unis nous le savons notamment des
républicains américains et de l'Union
européenne il est essentiel de rappeler
à quel point nous sommes derrière le
peuple ukrainien qui est un peuple
debout qui est un peuple sûr de sa
victoire je me suis rendu deux fois en
Ukraine depuis le début de la guerre et
je crois que en protégeant les
Ukrainiens nous nous protégeons
nous-mêmes nous protégeons certes nos
valeurs mais nous protégeons aussi notre
intégrité territoriale parce qu'à
vouloir faire la Grande Russie Vladimir
Poutine est capable de n'avoir aucune
limite je revient d'Arménie ancienne
république soviétique où la question
aussi de l'ancienne alliance avec la
Russie est aujourd'hui posée je crois
que Vladimir Poutine n'a aucune limite
et que l'Union européenne doit faire son
œuvre faire son travail c'est-à-dire
soutenir très activement le peuple
ukrainien oui ça j'y crois beaucoup un
dernier mot sur les européennes puisque
vous n'avez toujours pas désigné votre
tête de liste et pourtant hier encore
Éric sootti disait que François Xavier
bami avait toutes les qualités pour
porter ce projet est-ce que votre retard
à l'allumage risque de vous coûter cher
dans les urnes la dernière fois nous
avons choisi notre tête de liste fin
janvier je ne crois pas que les Français
soient encore dans les élections
européennes mais en même temps vous avez
fait 8 % là Jordan Bardella il est parti
en campagne depuis longtemps il est en
tête dans les sondages est-ce que du
coup vous ne risquez pas de faire encore
moins mais Jordan Bardella et le
rassemblement national sont toujours
très haut dans les sondages à 6 mois des
élections et ensuite il baisse au fur et
à mesure au fur et à mesure que les
Français se rendent compte que ce qu'ils
racontent sont souvent des balivverne
parce qu'il va falloir quand même que
chacun sorte de ses ambiguïtés il va
falloir qu'il y ait une heure de vérité
est-ce que le rassemblement national est
pour ou contre le projet européen est-ce
que le rassemblement national est pour
ou contre l'euro mais posez-leur la
question parce que vous verrez à quel
point ils sont ambigus et du côté de la
majorité présidentielle est-ce que euh
la prochaine tête de liste macronienne
est pour ou contre le fédéralisme et
pour ou contre diluer la souveraineté
française dans l'Union européenne mais
que chacun dise clairement ce qu'il
pense et nous nous sommes au clair
c'estàdire que nous voulons reprendre la
main comme par exemple nous voulons le
faire en matière migratoire et nous
voulons passer d'une Europe passoire à
une Europe puissance parce que l'Europe
doit être puissante et indépendante par
rapport à la Chine par rapport aux
États-Unis et par rapport aux g du
numérrique dernière question fa est-ce
que c'est justement cette ambigué de
rassemblement national dont vous nous
parlez ne contribue-elle pas au
grand remplacement pardon de la droite
traditionnelle la
vôre alors vous savez on ne sort de son
ambiguïé qu'à son détriment le jour où
nous dénoncerons sur les plateaux de
télévision et je reviendrai ici avec
plaisir pour le faire face à un député
européen rassemblement national vous
verrez qu'effectivement il narrivent pas
à sortir de leurs ambiguïés en fait ils
viennent à Bruxelles chercher leur paye
en étant députés européens mais pour
pour fustiger le projet européen parce
que Bruxelles beaucoup dire beaucoup de
réform à
faire l'euro la monnaie unique est-ce
qu'ils sont pour ou contre ils ne
répondent jamais nous allons leur poser
la question pendant le débat européen
merci Jef merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin merci Fabrice la
semaine prochaine